comme tant d'autres personnes tu sais
quoi je pense que le prochain spectacle
devrait être une comédie musicale tu es
magnifique tu es magnifique
le public sera intéressé par vos
motivations d'utiliser une mère porteuse
nous voyons son utérus c'est votre bébé
est-ce que tu te rends compte on va
enfin avoir un bébé
si on s'occupe bien d'elle elle
s'occupera bien du bébé
[Musique]
ça va mec parce que demain c'est la
première vous voyez il a sa fiancé dans
une chambre si on fait tous dans une
autre il ne sait plus trop donner de la
tête
[Musique]
on fait quoi maintenant je ne sais pas
on doit y réfléchir
[Musique]
est-ce que tu vas m'écouter merde
j'ai le choix si je veux dire non si je
veux pas je veux pas alors pourquoi tu
et qu'est-ce que tu lui as dit je
voulais aller la rejoindre là-bas
dois
gérer ça toi
[Musique]